[Music]
chuck got another explainer here except
i'm not i'm not going to be the one
doing the explaining uh-oh
i love it because it's stuff that
there's a whole lot of stuff i don't
know nothing about right and
you know so that's that's not true
i love the fact i mean i like it that
you try to be humble there's not like a
whole lot of stuff
that you don't know nothing about
which is why which is why i call you
black google so
so uh there's been high anticipation for
the artemis one launch yes for nasa this
is the return to the moon oh my gosh we
have been there in 50 years oh my god
but supposedly to make um preparations
for us to be there in the future as well
right well well let's find out yeah you
gotta go there first to go before you go
there a second time
so uh we combed the nasa landscape and
we found a system engineer at johnson
space center
in uh in houston texas this is you know
this is the center it's the nexus of the
crude flight present past present and
future of nasa and we found nejued
did i pronounce your name right now jude
yes you did thank you neil
excellent you got 20 years in system
engineering at johnson space flight
center and this is remarkable that means
you've seen a lot of different things
happen
like the space station uh the planning
stages and all of this
so uh you're the right person for this
for this explainer video so let's just
get straight to it okay
let's jump in let's do it what is
artemis one
so artemis is the whole enterprise of
nasa's efforts to return to the moon
with people again so for the first time
in over 50 years so that includes the
space launch system the orion spacecraft
ground system support mission control
all of those things and artemis one is
our first uncrewed test flight of the
rocket and the spaceship that will
return humans to the moon in the future
wow wow
so first of all let me just pause on
that 50-year gap because i think we last
we our last toe touched the moon in 1972
if memory serves apollo 17 and that was
50 freaking years ago and i'm thinking
what was around 50 years before
that date it was 1922
and flying cloth airplanes then
so let me just say i'm a little
disappointed that we're all getting
getting giddy over going back to where
we were 50 years ago i just want to put
that out there well you know we just
wanted to be sure
[Laughter]
and remind me i forget all my greek
mythology artemis is who
artemis is the twin sister of apollo so
apollo was you know the legacy we're
building on um and we're so named
artemis because this time when we return
to the moon we go with the first women
and people of color so a very diverse
astronaut core and we get to be named
after artemis well that's that's pretty
cool okay so they thought this through
very very very good so they said they
say that that that they that part of
this
this is of course when you read in the
the publications
i don't know if people are being a
little hyperbolic or they're just trying
to gin up some kind of excitement but
they're saying that this is the
precursor to
colonization of the moon so that we can
get to mars
is that is that kind of what you guys
are doing or or is that just kind of a
bunch of hype
no it is kind of what we're doing right
our goal so when apollo happened right
nasa was spending five percent of the
federal budget huge amount i like the
way you said i think you said apollo
happened
like it just happened
100 billion dollars 10 000 engineers a
scientist a dead president's promise
effort did you guys see what happened
this morning
i don't know i don't know if you were
around but did you see what happened
this morning we landed on the moon it
happened they shot a dude up into the
sky
and he landed on the moon
apollo happened
that's like engineers like like take
their stuff for granted right listen to
you i love it okay go on
all right so but today we don't get five
percent of the federal budget so the
idea is that we are very sustainable all
the bits and pieces needed to not just
explore the moon but continue on to mars
by the way the budget is one tenth that
now correct yes it's half of one percent
of the federal budget for all children
one all of us all absolutely all of nasa
mars rovers james webb everything oh my
god okay let me just say that is
disgusting i mean seriously
that is really
just completely and utterly
like awful but go ahead
all right well with that money we are
able to do all these things to return to
the moon and a lot of what we do on the
moon are the same types of things we
need to be able to build and demonstrate
to go to mars so very much artemis is
looking to also expand into the future
the mars exploration so now what do you
say to the people who
kind of think that
this is um an american move
to
kind of claim the moon because china and
russia are making noises like yo if we
get there we're taking it it's going to
be ours
like the moon is out the moon belongs
right hi i'm by the way i'm xi jinping i
am the head of china and the moon
by the way
chuck yeah uh the russians were the
first to fly to the far side of the moon
and if you look at the names of a lot of
the features there it's all
russian all right they were the first to
lay eyes upon it photograph it they got
to name it so yeah there's some of this
first come first serve thing so
um are you
is the engineer class among you in this
project are you sort of um
folded into the politics of it as well
or not
so i mean generally speaking we stay
clear of the politics we like to just
build cool things right
excellent
and for artemis one right the artemis
accords is nasa's initiative to do this
internationally um i think there's 13 or
14 countries that have already signed
the accords and for example on artemis
one the service module on the orion
spacecraft is built and provided by the
european space agency so artemis is an
international endeavor and when we build
the gateway uh the japanese space agency
the canadians and europeans have already
contributed to the gateway that is
starting to build elements out for the
orbiting habitat in the future so
nasa's leading an international
coalition and the engineers just get to
work with all the more cool people
jude i
i'm i i think what you said is quite
impressive however i did not hear uh the
country china mentioned at all
did you just say she builds stuff okay
it's the politicians we elect
someone else
exactly all right so so we've been to
the moon before but this is sort of new
architecture as we say new new um design
what are the highest risks of this
mission
like what could go wrong
oh uh well in space flight a lot could
go wrong at any time right it's
the whole rocket is just a giant fuel
tank with engines on the back right it's
enormous so obviously there's always
things that can go wrong with the rocket
but that's why orion especially for crew
in the future has a launch abort system
on it so we will have full abort
capability throughout all of the ascent
profile
when we get into space of course
anything that goes wrong on orion
the systems could have problems you know
you know solar array issues things like
that so we have lots of aborts and
contingencies to return orion home
sooner if anything happens um that's
nasa right we plan for all the
contingencies and have uh
plans bailouts
scenarios all have been run to assume
what we can do to recover the vehicle
and the biggest safety measure you have
on this mission is that there are no
people on it
right and this is something we can do
because of modern software and
technology and communications that
apollo couldn't right and remote
robotics and everything right we can fly
a massively complex first mission 42
days critical burns on the far side of
the moon without ground control
communication all without crew and test
the vehicle so obviously our first step
in safety is not putting the crew on the
first one to verify that everything
works
wow so when you talk about this being so
much more complex but then you have all
of this kind of like um computer help
do you increase
points of failure with all of this
complexity or does the kind of i'm sure
you're using ai and that kind of stuff
does that mitigate it
i'll check chuck when i first heard the
space shuttle get described as it's the
most complex space thing ever launched
and i say that can't be good exactly
that's what
that is you don't want to brag about
that right so as an engineer
as an engineer
what is your balance between the
complexity to get stuff done and the
simplicity to make sure nothing breaks
there's got to be some intersection of
those curves where you say that's where
i want to put it
there's certainly a bathtub curve where
you find the right place right you know
the more redundancy you put on is really
the more opportunity something can fail
so generally speaking you try to make
things as simple as you can
and then provide just enough redundancy
so there's a lot of probability analysis
risk analysis that goes into it to make
sure we're doing what we need to and not
more than that awesome so i've always
wondered and okay just because this is
my sci-fi mind thinking here so like the
human brain has a certain plasticity to
it that if one part of it is not working
another part can kind of compensate do
you guys oh wait chuck just because your
brain is made of plastic
don't assume anybody else
let's take that back my brain is made of
melted plastic
[Laughter]
let's be real right but do you do you
guys like overlap instead of just fail
safe do you have systems that overlap
that can compensate
so especially in what we do mission
planning um that's where we get as much
out of it as we can where we share
capabilities between vehicles so when we
go to the moon orion will dock with the
human landing system to take the crew
down to the surface so in a lot of times
we'll actually look to share redundancy
and capability across vehicles so that
way if something is happening on one
vehicle we can use the other vehicle as
a lifeboat
for example so mission planning can do
that at a bigger scale where we make
sure between the gateway the lander and
orion we can plan the most contingency
and fault tolerance between them not
just all on one vehicle
okay i got to just
reestablish the vocabulary here yeah
we've all seen these terms space launch
system
orion
artemis
what
what is what is the superset and what is
the subset of those set of words
yeah so artemis is the superset that's
the whole program and all of the
constituent parts
like apollo program like right apologies
got it got it okay holo had the saturn v
rocket and the apollo spacecraft right
together that was apollo
in our case artemis is the umbrella and
underneath it for especially this first
mission we have the space launch system
which is the big orange rocket
and the orion spacecraft whose job it is
to take in the future crew from the
earth to the moon and return them back
in the atmosphere and land in the safely
to the before the decade is out yes okay
uh how many uh how many people will it
take
it will take four crew um and orion on
its own could fly for up to 21 days with
those four crew with all the food and
water and systems they need
cool
and have you ever thought about
strapping a tesla to the front of it
i'm not sure that has a big benefit in
our mission
but she'll take that into under
advisement chuck on the next one on the
next message so happen to be on the moon
we might use it as a rover there you go
so uh will anything land or are you
gonna go there orbit and then come back
for artemis one uh we're going into a
distant retrograde orbit so a very big
orbit around the moon it retrograde
means the opposite direction of the
moon's rotation so that's the orbit
we're using as the test flight
so no landing on this mission um while
we're doing this the systems are being
built so that we can land crew hopefully
by artemis iii
so arteries two is now being conceived
but also with no crew
artemis ii will be our first crewed
flight for sls and orion so it's a
demonstration of all the crude systems
and life support
we have a very different mission profile
for that though just to be just to be
clear chuck
when she says crude she doesn't mean
c-r-u-d-e
right okay
these are these aren't crude
uh so we they they they basically
degenerize the the vocabulary from
manned missions to crude missions
you know i kind of like the uh
the first version better like which
which one the crew just like guys oh
crude
what are we high school students here
well i'm sure there's plenty of potty
jokes with the waste management system
exactly
it was if yeah because if that's up for
20 how many days they're drinking their
own urine they're drinking their own
urine and sweat aren't they orion is not
closed loop um so it's open loop so it's
dumping the urine and the humidity
overboard when we get to longer duration
systems like the gateway which will be
an orbiting outpost they'll have closed
closed-loop life support and recycle uh
water in here wait wait you're telling
me they're pee icicles
floating in earth moon orbit that's what
you just told me
uh sure shuttles are the same thing
right let me just send
that is awesome okay
that is that is the best thing i've ever
heard about any space mission
is that
they drop frozen poop and pee
that is now in
leaving your mark on the universe right
there yeah and it'll never go away i
mean achieve some stable orbit you'll
just be there like forever yeah and it's
yeah right right
okay and so uh is there any is this
mostly an engineering test or is there
any science that gets to piggyback this
uh it's mostly an engineering test but
inside orion are some science payloads
in particular radiation payloads to
measure the radiation especially for
future crude missions right um and a few
other payloads there's also
uh electricity this would be solar
radiation just to be clear yes
there's also 11 cubesats being deployed
from space launch system which are doing
a variety of scientific studies um that
can go out to the moon or heliocentric
as long as you're going into orbit pack
the trunk
that's what that sounds like
that means you had excess payload you
had excess payload capacity that's what
that sounds like to me uh yeah so the
space launch system we had quite a few
launch opportunities with it um it's got
room for that mass capability um
how many payloads are in the future we
actually that's one of the things we
look at for between launch opportunities
versus mass versus objectives so we look
at all of that across all the missions
how much of this is reusable
so the orion capsule is the only part
that will land safely in the water it is
a lot of it is reusable the avionics all
the interior systems and i think after
refurbishment um potentially some of the
exterior systems and capsule as well
but the rockets are one way
the rockets are fully extended we get
maximum performance out of them and what
kind of what kind of fuel do you use
uh hydrogen and oxygen hydrogen oxygen
yeah and when it comes together chuck
you get
water yeah
[Laughter]
drink your exhaust but wait till it
cools down first
so
um a point you slipped in there uh
but i just want to make it clear if you
schedule a rocket part to return
it means it had fuel
as part of the total weight of the
system in order to burn that fuel to
execute a return trip
so you've subtracted from your total
payload capacity by building in
that ability isn't that correct
that is correct so if you plan a rocket
and you want to put the biggest payload
on it you need to burn all the fuel
getting that sped up to get into orbit
if you want to recover your stage you
can only put smaller payloads on it
because you need to save the fuel just
as you described to return and land
safely
and
time for just a couple more questions
here why are you going into retrograde
orbit
uh it's just the easiest orbit it lined
up well for all these objectives and it
is a very stable orbit so if orion did
nothing it would never leave that orbit
so it makes a great test orbit for this
mission okay cool
all right
using the earth and the moon gravity to
maintain that orbit so it's like a
lagrange point that it just sits there
and is highly stable look at that nice
nice that's kind of cool we spent we did
some lagrange talks yeah we had a few
times that was a great uh explorer yeah
yeah we love me some lag points of
lagrange
so so it's anything you want to add any
tidbits that that maybe the press
doesn't get or that we because we have a
highly space literate audience here so
you could get into some nuance if you
needed to
i just think um maybe one of the things
to discuss for artemis one um we have a
lot of variability that we were able to
plan into it so
the launch days we're planning for are
42 days missions so launch to landing
and we do all of that so we can line up
our landing for a sunlit pacific ocean
so that's so we can collect all the test
data with the cameras and the high speed
entry for the entry the parachutes all
those things so we used a lot of mission
planning to shape the mission to get the
objectives needed
now you could wait eight hours and then
land in the atlantic ocean couldn't you
not really because uh when you come back
from the moon
with the aerodynamic breaking you will
land at the point underneath the sun we
need to line it up so if you wait eight
hours then it's really just the atlantic
is in the same spot so you can't play
that game when you're coming back from
the moon because then the the atlantic
would be in the same spot but the sun
wouldn't be aligned for you
right
in the in the way you need it gotcha
gotcha interesting so is it going to be
another one of these things where
there's like an aircraft carrier and and
and a navy helicopter goes out and uh
you know and i'll feel like it's 60
years ago
uh similar so the navy is doing our
primary recovery they're using a
well-deck ship though that's a
well-decked ship
so it's actually got a big opening in it
and a door that comes down and they can
lower the back of the ship and actually
tow orion right into the ship and then
they close the gate pump the water out
and lift it up out of the water so it's
uh they don't have to lift orion with a
helicopter they literally float it into
the ship
oh that's a nice advancement
okay okay
all right we're good all right well this
this sounds this is great and one last
question are we pretty sure that the
moon doesn't have any
uh
any andromeda strain type bugs that
could
influence us so that when we send
astronauts there next are they going to
have to go through quarantine the way
the original astronauts did from apollo
so i think based on all of the apollo
data um they there's the planetary
protection requirements change there's
no known biological hazards so i don't
think they'll have to do nearly as much
quarantining as the apollo astronauts
did
when we go to mars those requirements
are still there because we'd have
unknown
uh biological conditions on mars so they
would be very different requirements
between the moon and mars right now
unknown unknowns yeah yeah and chuck you
get that she works for nasa so she gets
to say
when we go to mars you hear that i heard
you thought that
you caught that see when we go to mars
apollo happened and when we go to mars
that's how they speak over and out
now jude this has been a delight uh
thank you for plugging us in to this uh
historic return to the moon it's long
overdue of course
and i'd like to know that you're in arms
reach of us uh maybe to catch up on any
new developments uh either during the
mission or after the mission or or as we
approach artemis two and three
certainly i'm always around and i don't
have to work operations so i'm available
during the mission
you're done okay
oh wow we did our job they got to go fly
our mission you tightened that last nut
on the on the on the bolt and you're
you're good okay so now
okay i'm i'm i hate to ask this but i
got to so your part is done if something
goes wrong is this is this one of these
things where it's easily identified or
is it like when you put in a window in
your home and it's like yeah that's a
manufacturing problem and yeah and the
window company's like nah that's an
installation problem
well i guarantee looking at post flight
data there will be some of those
arguments
okay
how do you solve problems this is a
flight test you do it to learn okay that
that's that's cool so problems are i
guess problems are welcome because if
this is the time to have them
i would rather we find all the problems
and shake it out right now before we put
the crew on
chuck chuck as they say and i don't know
if
you'd admit to this but as they say as
the rocket engineers say if the rocket
blows up on the launch pad he said oh
that's a tragedy they said no
that was an event
high in data
rich environment oh my god a data rich
environment let's talk about gallows
humor that's
i love it though it's a data risk but
you'd want sensors all around so that
you actually can obtain the temperature
pressures you know all the rest of the
normal things you'd get
yeah and the rocket and spacecraft are
carrying tons of extra data sensors and
recording units that they wouldn't carry
in the future for that purpose
and just to be clear because we have
like 30 seconds left um for people who
are thinking about this kind of career
isn't it true
um i know in the sciences you're
expected to go for a phd to be a sort of
participating member of the scientific
community but the engineering community
you could be hired right out of college
with an engineering degree
and maybe you get a master's too
okay yeah so
so and the phd engineers aren't
typically the ones who are getting their
hands dirty they return and become like
professors right and teach the next
generation so
uh in engineering the masters
or the undergraduate degree can be
considered terminal degrees for that
profession
vast majority of the folks i work with
myself included started out of their
undergrad engineering degrees that's
that's what you do and most of what you
do after that is learn on the job i did
get a master's but that's like more of
the minority share but you're right phd
engineers are mostly research and
professors they're not there are phd
engineers here but that's not like a
requirement by any means yeah it's not
the thing right wow right that's uh
that's
pretty exciting
yeah yeah it is it means you can get in
right up off the bat right off the bat
because the delay there's a leaky
pipeline in the sciences right where you
you get your undergraduate degree and
they got your master's in the phd that's
six years
you know you're not really a whole
citizen yet of the practicing community
until you're done with that and then a
postdoc and by by time that happens if
you're 10 years older than you would
have otherwise been in a job had you
gotten an engineering degree so wow yeah
just want to put that out there for
those who are thinking about this so we
guys we got to end it there but it's
been a delight to have you nejued and we
look forward to having you back for
future developments in the artemis
program uh chuck always good to have you
man oh it's a pleasure
all right this is neil degrasse tyson
your personal astrophysicist as always
bidding you
to keep looking up
as nasa
[Music]
you